the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire update video well
my friends it looks like we have another
incredible update from the man the myth
and the legend himself mr george r
martin now in this new update he reveals
some new shocking information about how
he will end a song of ice and fire as a
matter of fact he finally admitted to
something i had known all along
let's go over to his not a blog website
once again so you can see exactly what i
mean the name of this new update is a
winter garden george rr martin says i've
done a lot of interviews over the years
more than i can even keep track of
inevitably a lot of them are on the same
subjects
one of the things i have been asked
about most is how i write my novels now
if you've seen any of those interviews
you have most likely heard me talking
about the two types of writers the
architects and the gardeners i have
given the same spiel numerous times now
another question that i get a lot
especially since the end of game of
thrones on hbo is whether a song of ice
and fire will end the same way an
architect would be able to give a short
concise simple answer to that but as you
all know i'm much more of a gardener my
stories grow and evolve and change as i
write them i generally know where i'm
going sure the final destinations the
big set pieces they've been in my head
for years for decades in the case of a
song of ice and fire there are lots of
devils in the details though and
sometimes the ground changes under my
feet as the words move forth another
question fans and interviewers alike ask
a lot is where do you get your ideas
honestly i wish i knew when confronted
with the same question harlan ellison
used to say schenectady the ancient
greeks spoke of the muses
freud talked to the conscious and
subconscious minds the id the ego the
superego now more recently we hear about
the right brain and the left brain one
analytic and rational the other
imaginative and creative i'm sure the
answer is not schenectady but aside from
that hell i don't know yes now there are
some instances where i know the seed
from which something in my garden sprang
the wall sprang from my visit to
hadrian's wall in 1981. the war of the
roses inspired much of game of thrones
and the red wedding was a mashup of the
glencoe massacre and the black dinner
from scottish history but for every
instance like that there are a hundred
for which i have to say i don't know
one day the thought just came to me it
wasn't there and then it was now this is
what brings him to the winds of winter
most of you know by now that i do not
like to give detailed updates on the
winds of winter i'm working on it i have
been working on it and i will continue
to work on it yes i do work on other
things as well i love nothing more than
to surprise my readers with twists and
turns they did not see coming and i risk
losing those moments if i go into too
much detail even saying that i'm working
on a tyrian chapter as i did last week
gives away the fact that tyrion is not
dead reading sample chapters at
conventions or uploading them online
which i did for years gives away even
more i actually quite enjoyed doing that
until the day came that i realized i had
read or shared the first couple hundred
pages from the winds of winter or
thereabouts if i'd kept on with the
readings half of the book might already
be out by now so i'm not going to give
all of you any kind of detailed report
on the novel but i will say this i have
been at work in my winter garden things
are growing and changing as does happen
with us gardeners things twist things
change new ideas come to me old ideas
prove unworkable and i write i rewrite i
restructure i rip everything out and
rewrite again i go through doors that
lead nowhere in doors that open up on
marvel's it sounds mad i know but it's
how i write always has been always will
be for good or for the ill alright folks
now this is where things get very
interesting he says what i've noticed
more and more of late however is my
gardening is taking me further and
further away from the television show
yes some of the things you saw on hbo in
a game of thrones you will also see in
the winds of winter though maybe not in
quite the same ways however much of the
rest will be quite different and really
when you think about it this was
inevitable the novels are much bigger
and much much much more complex than the
show certain things that happened on hbo
will not happen in the novels i have
viewpoint characters in the books never
seen on the show victarion greyjoy
ariane martell aria hota john connington
and aaron damper they will all have
chapters and the things they do and say
will impact the story and the major
characters who were on the show i have
legions of secondary characters not povs
but nonetheless important to the main
plot who will also figure in the story
lady stoneheart young griff the tattered
prince penny brown ben plum the shave
pate marwinda mage darkstar and jane
westerling some characters you saw on
the show are very different than the
versions in the novels yara greyjoy is
not asha greyjoy and hbo's geron greyjoy
is way way way way different from mine
yeah i think some of us did notice quay
still has her own part to play and so
does rickon stark and even jane pull
and well the list is very long and all
of this is why the winds of winter has
taken so long this is hard guys
oh and there will be new characters as
well
no new viewpoints i swear on that but
with all these journeys and battles and
scheming to come inevitably our major
characters will be encountering new ones
in lands far and near one thing i can
say in general enough terms that i will
not be spoiling anything not all of the
characters who survived until the end of
a game of thrones will survive until the
end of a song of ice and fire and not
all of the characters who died on game
of thrones will die in a song of ice and
fire now i do wonder might this be a
reference to daenerys targaryen someone
that a lot of the fans were upset with
when she died in the show
george rr martin finishes by saying some
will sure of course maybe most but
definitely not all now of course i could
change my mind again next week with the
next chapter that i write that's how
gardening works in the ending you will
need to wait until i get there
some things will be the same a lot will
not
no doubt once i'm done there will be a
big debate about which version of the
story is better now if i'm being honest
george i think most fans have already
decided
some will like my book others will like
the television show and that's fine now
i do fear that a certain section of the
fans are so angry about how long the
winds of winter has taken me that
they're ready to hate the book even
without reading it that saddens me but
there's nothing i can do about that all
i can do is write the best book that i
can and hope that when it's released
most fans will read it with a clean
hands and open mind that's all i can
tell you right now i need to get back to
my garden lord tyrion is waiting for me
well there you have it ladies and
gentlemen you've now heard it once again
from the man himself the ending of a
song of ice and fire will not be the
same as the ending of a game of thrones
now he's also said that no matter how
the fans react he would not make any
changes to his story but with that being
said i still wonder if the reaction to
the ending of a game of thrones affected
him or his writing in any way i imagine
that it must have in some way but i
guess we'll never know for sure unless
he comes out and says so himself
let me know what all of you think about
this new update if i'm being honest i've
known this all along i've even said it
in numerous videos but it's always nice
to hear it from the author himself if we
ever do get the real ending to a song of
ice and fire it will not look the same
as the ending from the television show
unfortunately none of this will really
matter unless he actually releases the
damn novel we can never debate about
which is better if we never get his
version
as of right now the only ending we have
is what hbo has given us
or i should say what dan and dave has
given us i think i can speak for most
fans when i say george we are begging
you for your real ending
now get your ass back to that garden
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching this video leave me your
thoughts on all of this down below
have a great day everyone i will see you
soon in the next video
bye
[Music]
so
so
you